okay Ron enough snuff let's talk plans
for Diane's baby chef dear God woman
three main activities baby bingo baby
food tasting and my personal favorite
baby onesie decorating station I'm gonna
make mine look like an astronaut what
are you doing up there in space baby oh
so cute okay I have some gift ideas I
was looking at a very adorable stroller
we already have a stroller oh shoot
really have to think of something else
oh my god whose baby is that that would
be mine guys get in here Ron is a baby
Oh Ron cool baby
thank you Andrew everyone I'd like to
introduce you to my son John middle name
redacted Swanson John was born some time
ago weighing multiple pounds and several
ounces much like his father he is a fan
of silence please keep your voices down
how am I supposed to keep my voice down
when you had your baby baby why would
you need to know something like oh my
god I'm not even sent Diana gift she's
just walking around wondering why I
haven't sent her a gift yet should we do
something just let her tire cell phone
if you need anything from us Ronnie
please just let us know actually there
is something could one of you please
stop by the pet store and pick up some
fish food for me fish Jan is about to
have a baby with a sperm donor and
Michael is preparing for the birth of a
watermelon with the white now this baby
will be related to Michael through
delusion Michael yeah my waters breaking
okay okay what do you do I get a call
from Jan and I meet her at the hospital
right highways or surface roads
I take Quincey AB to Gibson no Gibson is
covered in potholes your car breaks down
adapt
I checked the route there are no
potholes come on yeah I knew the
circumstance you like to have my baby
yes yeah no I know I'm trying
babies are one of my many areas of
expertise growing up I perform my own
circumcision just keep pushing Oh baby
I'm right here I'm right here screaming
I'm screaming pushing free mommy up I
want anesthesia no you can't have it
it's too late no I don't want to just
push it out okay keep stimulated keeps
it a Sharpie yes okay wouldn't the baby
emerges market secretly in a kind of a
mark that only you can recognize and no
baby snatcher could ever copy ready yes
Oh God Wow
what was on that butter newborns are
slippery nice touch good let's try that
again
I just going to be the happiest day of
my life hey sorry about the mess hi
Cagney hi Lacey
hey you kids like the same kind of
cereal as me well we just made a
storytime
I'm gonna kiss the girls night night
then we can get down to business
time for night-night girls he is so
strong but so gentle it's like an
enormous muscular Ellen DeGeneres you
know I just won't let you guys know that
I love you girls so so much
okay so sleep tight you know daddy will
never leave you right girls
goodbye gosh really makes you understand
what he went through I'm worried about
Terry babe you look more beautiful right
now than I have ever seen you Wow
just your luck that you're going into
labor on Halloween can I get a warm
towel to get that makeup off no I went
on that's the whole point I put the
makeup on after I went into labor
whatever blows your skirt up okay are
you ready to push
wait don't babe my birth makes
here comes a contraction are you hurt
Macklin jr. we need a Halloween angle
how about demon spawn baby Satan Dwyer
oh I like that yeah or labored
snake-hole loud gate karate Dracula
Macklin demon Jacqueline from the way we
call him Jack for short I don't wake up
my godchild
I'm assuming it's my godchild right we
can talk about it later Congrats guys I
know it came unexpectedly early but
pretty cool he was born in Pawnee where
do I put these of so many presents it's
weird yes Oh for the baby just put over
there hello ladies
how was my shower going Phyllis did you
get the live storks No damn it Phyllis
I'm sorry damn it Phyllis it was hard
enough to convince Jane to come so are
we set for refreshments per your
instructions we have the personalized
M&Ms with the baby names this is your
boy bowl with the name Chevy that was me
and this is the girl Bowl with M&Ms with
the name a stirred there can't be right
Michael wrote down asked her she said it
is the name of a Viking princess
so ass true I know I don't know it is
beautiful
no thank you is this it I mean is this
two bowls of M&Ms and some balloons
you know what Phyllis I think you need
to step it up I think you need to get
the lead out because if I'm not mistaken
we gave you your wedding shower here we
all came into this room and gave you a
golden shower well you know what where's
my golden shower Phyllis it does not
matter to me at all whether this baby is
biologically mine I'm going to love it
it's like when the dog nurses the tiger
cub have you seen that video
it is it's so bizarre and unnatural but
it happens
Jake do I see you for a minute oh yeah
it's a girl Sharon and I wanted you to
be the first person to meet Ava oh wow
she's beautiful I'm sorry I got angry
earlier I did a great job today a
hospital is the right decision
I'm so glad you're Avis Godfather I'm so
glad you're Sharon's god-husband I'm so
glad you're my god-wife I have no idea
what I'm saying at this point thank you
Jake holder oh yes the baby Jake yeah
right right the normal thing I never
thought this day would come Lizzy okay
here comes your baby congratulations
it's me Kirk CC plasters mascot I'm was
inside you
razzmatazz we need to go over the
schedule leading up to the primary let's
talk shop who shop Talk one of my five
favorite types of talk along with pillow
girl real and Ted why are you wearing a
poncho oh because every surface area in
your house is sticky last time I was
here I found it melted crayon on my
blazer okay I have a photo op with
grizzle tomorrow between now and then we
have a ton of stuff scheduled looks like
we're gonna have to skip the pie baking
event and ceremonial squash toss Oh skip
that I love watching those squashes fly
through the air I kind of like the way
they land me too excuse me I have to get
back to a city where things happen okay
this campaign is about to start an
Ernest things are about to get real
intense you ready oh yeah I already made
my pump up mix you know it's a
surprising amount of Pat Benatar nice
I was talking to Leslie me Leslie yeah
well I was an actual candidate so I
think I can handle being a candidates
wife I know all the issues inside and
out see that's the problem if you were
just a ding dong oh just slap a flag pin
on you pour some valium down your throat
yeah everything would be fine the
Smarties freak people out I think you're
under estimating the voters being the
wife of is a minefield right then you
know what do you think of it like sex
freshman year of college I just kind of
want to get through it as fast as
possible without embarrassing yourself
I'm using that as an analogy and help
you out because I'm assuming you're a
late bloomer not me I crushed it from
day one Oh Stephen be careful Oh patch
oh there's my little niblets Halpert
room d100 right family only beyond this
point thank you yeah we go
no don't push nope not yet not yet not
yet I go wash my eyes back it's gonna
have a lot of air
you